[Musica]
udire sentire ascoltare tre verbi
diversi che non indicano la stessa cosa
quando il nostro sistema
somatosensoriale quando le nostre
orecchie sono toccate da un'onda sonora
Noi percepiamo un suono Noi odiamo
qualcosa quando questo suono diventa
qualcosa di continuato e con noi
sentiamo un rumore sentiamo una musica a
volte sentiamo anche un sentimento
ascoltare Ecco ascoltare è diverso
ascoltare non richiede solo noi richiede
anche un tu richiede anche un qualcuno
che commenti che comunichi qualcosa
ascoltare e richiedere il linguaggio ma
il linguaggio di nuovo non è una cosa
solo degli uomini le api comunicano tra
di loro con la loro danza mediante
questo linguaggio che è fondamentale per
la sopravvivenza della loro Specie anche
le scimmie comunicano con un linguaggio
conosciamo Delle specie di scimmie che
addirittura hanno la capacità di fare il
verso vi arriva il leone quando un loro
competitola in mano una gustosa banana e
un'altra scimmia la vuole rubare non
siamo neanche l'unica specie che mente
Ecco però il nostro linguaggio
differente il nostro linguaggio ha una
caratteristica che è solo nostra che è
la sintassi soggetto verbo e complemento
oggetto e noi possiamo avere tanti o
fare tanti errori possiamo non essere in
grado di pronunciare correttamente una
parola in una certa lingua quando sono
stato negli Stati Uniti e ho conosciuto
nostri connazionali immigrati 40 anni fa
e dopo 40 anni ancora non sanno dire
Orange dicono orangio ma non invertono
mai il soggetto con il verbo perché ecco
per tanti anni noi ci siamo chiesti come
era possibile che noi parlassimo con un
linguaggio sintattico ma è un po' come
chiederti perché un martello è il manico
fatto in quella maniera Evidentemente
perché la ma non lo vuole afferrare
parliamo così perché il nostro cervello
la nostra mente è capace di articolare
un pensiero sintattico ma dicendo questo
ancora non abbiamo risposto alla più
importante domanda dietro al linguaggio
A cosa serve Ecco un martello serve per
schiacciare i chiodi e il linguaggio la
parola questo nostro modo di comunicare
che è costato così tanta impegno
evolutivamente parlando alla nostra
mente per essere acquisito a cosa serve
con una parola che io vi dicessi sono
triste sono felice immediatamente
permetto alla vostra immaginazione di
vedere qualcosa che altrimenti è
invisibile vedete di me qualcosa che non
è possibile osservare da fuori il
linguaggio serve a questo il linguaggio
serve a mettere un membro della nostra
specie in grado di vedere qualcosa che
altrimenti è invisibile il linguaggio
istruisce l'immaginazione con il
linguaggio noi mappiamo la realtà
rendendola qualcosa riconosciuto creano
il mondo trasmettiamo il mondo ai nostri
simili ma con il linguaggio facciamo
anche delle cose che sono profondamente
delle strutture che non esistono in
natura Supponiamo che io vi faccia
vedere un filmato che vi interessi
naturalmente ad altissima definizione
dell'ultimo pranzo di famiglia che ha
fatto la mia famiglia a Natale video
interessantissimo per carità ma se io
non vi dicessi a parole che quella
signora seduta un angolo della sala da
pranzo e la vecchia zia Maria voi non lo
potreste capire li video non dice tutto
abbiamo bisogno della parola per dire
qualcosa in più la tecnologia che
abbiamo sviluppato è la tecnologia di
linguaggio ma evidentemente linguaggio
non serve a tutto se io mi dovessi
spiegare a parole come si fa un nodo io
dovrei dire prendete il capo ha girato
intorno al capo B Inverti
complicatissimo è molto più semplice
farvi vedere un tutorial Ecco perché non
basta la parola Ecco perché ci abbiamo i
fax internet gli sms e anche WhatsApp
Ma di questa tecnologia A me interessa
soprattutto una funzione che oggi è
utilissima che ogni giorno è utilissimo
diceva bernar Russel un famoso filosofo
del secolo scorso che con linguaggio noi
possiamo produrre una cosa che si chiama
lo slittamento lui lo commentava così
nessun cane vi potrà mai dire che il
figlio di due onesticani per quanto
poveri o nel linguaggio noi spostiamo
gli eventi dalla storia vi posso far
vedere far conoscere una cosa che non
c'è più noi siamo una specie che ha la
storia
di stagione
tutte le storie che raccontiamo sono
tutte esistite davvero Ecco c'è una
forma c'è un uso del nostro linguaggio
che in realtà possiamo utilizzare per
raccontare qualcosa che non è esistito
ma che a rispondere ad alcune domande di
fondo del nostro essere si chiama mito
quando ci chiediamo Perché è così
difficile vivere l'amore tra un uomo e
una donna Ecco che un racconto di due
amanti e rosse e Psiche e di notte si
amano così profondamente e che di giorno
psiche per scoprire chi è il volto di
questa amato così passionale rischia di
ucciderlo non è la storia di un episodio
che non è mai è successo ma è
semplicemente un modo che abbiamo per
rispondere a questa domanda che da
sempre ci accompagna perché amare è
difficile e allora il linguaggio nella
forma del mito è una forma di conoscenza
che serve a rispondere ad alcune delle
domande più profonde che abitano il
nostro cuore
di tutti i miti però ce n'è uno che è
molto importante e il mito dell'eroe la
vita di ciascuno di noi non è semplice
la vita di ciascuno di noi affronta
delle sfide la vita di ciascuno di noi
chiede di essere indirizzata verso una
meta verso un obiettivo che può fare di
una vita qualcosa che vale la pena di
essere vissuta o semplicemente un
tentativo fallito
regione dei nostri perché
sono solo qualcosa che abita il passato
il mito È solo qualcosa che sta tra Eros
e Psiche Ulisse sono solo qualcosa che
possiamo leggere sul nostro comodino
Ecco in realtà un famoso antropologo
Joseph Campbell ci ha raccontato che il
mito dell'eroe continua a vivere di
narrazione in narrazione di storia e in
storia e grazie dell'opera di Joseph
Campbell quella che è a mio giudizio
Perdonatemi non faccio lo Jedi ma faccio
il fan è stata realizzata la più bella
opera di fantascienza Star Wars Star
Wars non è altro che la saga dell'eroe
raccontata oggi Star Wars ci dice che
l'eroe che noi ancora bisogno di storia
è ancora bisogno di rispondere a quella
domanda Ecco i miti ora non abitano più
storie nel passato fuori dal tempo ma
abitano storie nel futuro quello che una
volta erano i grandi racconti epici Oggi
sono le serie che in streaming
consumiamo sui nostri device e
soprattutto la fantascienza il luogo
dove il mito abita per eccellenza Ne
volete un esempio
di produzione americana IC quella che ha
fatto il Trono di Spade ha investito
tantissimo per produrre un nuovo una
nuova serie di fantascienza che si
chiama westward giuro eh Non faccio
spoiler però all'interno di questa serie
si racconta di un parco di divertimenti
a tema Come tanti che ne stanno sognando
nel mondo che ha come tema il mondo West
all'interno di questo parco di
divertimenti Che cosa accade Che c'è un
grande ingegnere che realizza i
divertimenti addirittura Anthony Hopkins
recita in questa serie e questo grande
ingegnere realizza gli attori
di intelligenza artificiale
sofisticatissimo e gli ospiti io e voi
Se volessimo possono fare tutto quello
che vogliono perché non ci sono
conseguenze e da qui il sottotitolo
westworld dove tutto è possibile La
storia è abbastanza banale reset dopo
reset questi Robot si ribellano all'uomo
Perdonatemi un secondo
abbiamo un creatore abbiamo una creatura
Abbiamo un giardino la creatura si
ribella al suo creatore mi sembra una
storia già sentita Ecco allora c'è
spazio anche per la teologia e allora
guardare al mito guardare a quello che
consumiamo nei nostri device ci aiuta a
far vedere delle domande che abitano il
nostro cuore e che forse non escono nel
nostro oggi ascoltiamo questi miti e
vediamo
il 900 avevano davanti a sé una cosa che
si chiamava utopia un luogo da
realizzare per avere un nostro domani
Oggi Beh che cosa sogniamo sogni
negli Stati Uniti di realizzare una
città perfetta
progettata da alcuni artista con una
legge proprio con un sistema perfetto si
chiama prospera non sognano
l'altro con una realtà che ci ha deluso
diventa un problema e per tutti gli
altri per tutti coloro che non sono
ricchi Beh ci ha promesso il metaverso
cioè promesso di andare in un luogo che
non è un luogo dove potremmo plasmare
almeno in teoria tutti i nostri desideri
Sì prospera è una plutopia il metaverso
è un atopia un luogo senza luogo E
allora Sì siamo di nuovo di fronte ai
miti perché siamo di nuovo di fronte
alle domande più profonde che abitano
nel cuore di ciascuno di noi se abbiamo
il coraggio di utilizzare questa
categoria per interrogare il nostro
presente e Allora potremmo ascoltare i
nostri sogni e i nostri desideri Grazie
[Applauso]